pour avoir le maillot des joueurs et
comme ça ça fait un souvenir un peu
c'était la chasse aux maillot et aux
autographes ce lundi 2 octobre le Pays
de Galles a ouvert un de ses
entraînements au public versaillé au
stade de porschefontaine cet après-midi
ils étaient plus de 1000 supporters
autour du terrain on souhaite une bonne
chose qui soit là de voir qui
s'entraînent c'est un plus c'est un plus
pour Versailles et pour le pour le club
de Versailles je pense on a une chance
aujourd'hui de pouvoir aller voir
s'entraîner et puis leur rendre hommage
et honneur en fait en étant présent
autour du stade après un entraînement
d'une heure le 15 du poireau s'est prêté
un bain de foule auprès du public un
moment de partage qui a duré une dizaine
de minutes
on espère rester plus longtemps dans le
tournoi pour profiter de ce bel endroit
j'adore la France je sais que la France
est une terre de rugby et les Français
sont de très bons supporters installé
dans la cité royale sur la pelouse du
Rugby Club de Versailles pendant toute
la Coupe du monde du rugby la ville se
félicite de l'engouement généré par la
venue des rugmann britanniques pendant
la compétition certes on a ouvert le 3
septembre mais on a enfin la récompense
de les voir sur site et surtout de le
faire partager à notre population donc
le premier entraînement vers au public
de ce vendredi et aujourd'hui le second
voilà on le prend comme une récompense
pour la population pour les agents qui
se sont investis et sous un magnifique
soleil donc on ne peut être que ravi
prochain match pour les Gallois ce
samedi ils joueront leur dernier match
de poule face à la Géorgie à Nantes et
Dragon Rouge sont pour l'instant premier
et devrait se qualifier pour les quarts
de finale l'occasion pour le 15 du
poireau de prolonger son séjour à
Versailles au plus grand bonheur des
supporters